recently one of my YouTube viewers asked
a really great question something that I
thought was interesting enough to turn
into a video and that's what I'm doing
right here with another top 10 list so
the question was which ancient works of
philosophical literature that have been
lost and we don't have any longer would
you most like to have and be able to
read and find out what's going on in
them and so that that is a really
interesting idea because it's sort of
like getting what we used to call a grab
bag where where you you reach in and you
don't actually know what's there it
could turn out that that you know we get
a lost work by Epicurus and we're like
oh it wasn't very good after all was it
or we might be amazed at how how you
know brilliant it was as well so I I set
myself a couple of guidelines one was
you know I was gonna pick books that we
do know did exist at one time and were
referenced by by other authors another
was that I would pick 10 authors and
only pick one book from each of them
even though you know there are many
books by some of these authors that I
myself would would love to have because
I wanted to have a nice distribution of
them looking over it there's you know
quite a few from what we can call
pre-socratic literature some that are
directly Socratic and going all the way
down to the time of Cicero so we've got
quite a few authors in there so I'm just
going to tell you what my list is you're
perfectly capable of coming up with your
own list I would suggest that if you
want and you know figure out what's
actually out there one of the best
places you can go to is Diogenes lair
T's lives of the philosophers because he
gives us lists of books most of which we
no longer had but there's other places
where you can find out about ancient
literature as well so no further ado let
me start
number one and that is Heraclitus the
famous pre-socratic philosopher
oftentimes called Heraclitus the obscure
perhaps he would be less obscure if we
actually did possess what was seen to be
his masterwork on nature the the
fragments that we currently have are
derived from we think from that or from
things that that you know he's recorded
as having said it would be really
interesting to actually have this
because there was apparently we don't
know if there was a you know continuity
over time that there were some people
who were Heric Lydians throughout the
the history of ancient philosophy they
probably were a small group but perhaps
they were reading his his famous text
that it would be great to have access to
it so Heraclitus number one another
person who I think would be really cool
to have some works by is an older /
older sophist right and he was somebody
who who traveled around quite a bit
that would be protagonist we think
there's no reason really to doubt this
that Socrates as a young men got to meet
Protagoras in Athens and Protagoras
wrote quite a few books the one that I
think I would probably like to have the
most given what we know about him is
translated in Diogenes the the
translator in English calls that the art
of controversy in Greek it's techne
episteme Cohen so not necessarily
controversy but but the art or the the
discipline of figuring things out we
might say and Protagoras would be very
interesting it to get to see him in his
own words not just represented by say
Plato in a dialogue number three would
be another one of these you know people
that we call the Sophists these days
that would be gorgeous and gorgeous
this was a very interesting guy he
didn't claim to teach quite as much as
some of the other Sophists of the time
did he claim just to be able to teach
rhetoric the art of persuasion but we
know that he had some sort of
philosophical background as well he
wrote a book that's called a couple
different things it's called on nature
but it's also called
on non existant around the non-existent
and in it apparently he took on
Parmenides and the elaine ik school who
had argued that you know there really is
no motion i mean you can look at Zeno's
paradoxes as examples of that and he
presented some counter theses you could
say so that would be a really
interesting work to have particularly
for me as I have my own interest in
discussions about nothingness non-being
and its relationship with being and
truth then we start to get to Socratic
figures and I would really like to have
something by antis tonie's one of
Socrates students apparently antis
tonie's wrote a lot of stuff enough to
fill 10 volumes and we have exactly
nothing of those works so if in looking
through all of the things that that he
wrote there's a lot of tempting things
in there but one that I would
particularly like to have is translated
the title of it as of discussion a
handbook of debate in Greek period to
the legacy I want a log eCos Perry 2d
legacy means about that that the topic
of you know discussion back and forth
dialoguing working things through in
speech and then on Telugu coast has the
sense of like speaking in response or
against something else
so that would be you know probably one
of the most interesting works of him to
him although again if we we had access
to this maybe that one's not one of his
better works and one of the other ones
would be more interesting to possess
another key student of Socrates who also
founded his own school eros tipis he
wrote not quite as much as as some of
these other thinkers but he wrote quite
a bit and he's supposed to have written
a book on virtue parody honor tastes so
given that he is coming from the
Socratic tradition but he's deviating
from it considerably in that he's a
hedonist he's saying pleasure is the
good I would love to actually be able to
see what he thought virtue was and and
how we would make sense of it and I'm
sure in that book there'd be a lot more
discussion about psychology and pleasure
and pain and how to value things so that
would be very interesting to have then
for number six I have somebody who's not
a Socratic philosopher but who would be
kind of a contemporary I'm actually
doing this just a little bit out of
order
Epicurus Epicurus was supposed to have
been one of the most prolific authors in
antiquity and unfortunately we have
almost nothing that the guy wrote what
we do have is almost entirely due to the
fact that Diogenes Lyra taste thought
that Epicurus was so interesting that he
actually copied out entire works very
short works by hand and included them as
the end of his lives of the philosophers
so if Diogenes had done that we probably
would have lost all of Epicurus
he has a book or he had a book he will
discover it someday called on nature and
it was 37 books that means 37 Scrolls
worth of writing that would be very
interesting to read through wouldn't it
because apparently in ancient times the
the Koreans had access to that stuff as
did their opponents then we can jump
back a little bit in time to Aristotle I
mean these guys are more or less
contemporaries now Aristotle wrote a lot
of stuff and we do in fact have a lot of
stuff that Aristotle wrote and there was
even stuff that Aristotle didn't write
that survived that got attributed to
Aristotle but we are missing some things
and as opposed to some other people
would say I want the second book of the
poetics you know which was about comedy
that would be cool to have I think one
of the most interesting things would
have been to possess one of the various
constitutions that that Aristotle and
his his students carried out is like
case studies and if we look at the one
that we do have the constitution of
athens it's like a history of all of the
institutions and how they developed
through time and and the different you
know transformations so you know he did
these of over a hundred and forty Greek
city states including Athens which one
would we want to have the most you know
I think a lot of people would say Sparta
but you know what I would actually want
I would want the constitution of Thebes
because they think that could be very
interesting especially given the the
role that that the Thebans played in
recent history
in Aristotle's own time I mean if we had
other stuff on other people's then maybe
I'd want that but but we think there was
just Greek city-states so that is number
seven number eight the great stoic
author really the founder of the school
Zeno
he wrote quite a few things and I think
one that a lot of people would want to
have is his Republic but I would rather
have another work that Diogenes tells us
that Zeno wrote and that is called of
life according to nature
now why would I want that one in
particular because it's such an
important stoic concept there's so much
discussion about it and wouldn't it be
cool to have the guy who got it started
telling us what it actually meant for
him in his own words at that time
another author who's in the stomach
school who again like like Epicurus was
supposed to have been incredibly
prolific was cruciferous and we we have
a really fascinating listing in Diogenes
lair taste of all the books that that
that cruciferous is supposed to have
written most of them deal with
argumentation and and logical theory so
they're part of you know what what the
ancients called dialectic or logic I'm
more interested in the ethical stuff so
what I would if I only could have one
book by by cruciferous and again this is
like reaching into a grab bag and you
don't know what you're really gonna get
I would want his book on habit Perry
heck sales because it's such an
important concept not just you know for
the Stoics but in ancient philosophy in
general and I would love to see what
cruciferous himself had to say about
this and what he said in relation to the
other schools of the time because he
spent a lot of time in in you know sort
of polemics against them the last one
that I would want to have is again by an
author who we possessed quite a bit of
some some of which we only possess in
fragments or in text that that you know
give out at a certain point and then
would be Cicero Cicero wrote a book
called the Hortensius and we don't have
it but a lot of people in the ancient
world did and it turned out to be very
influential it's sort of an introduction
to philosophy and given that Cicero's
whole project was you know taking Greek
philosophy putting it into a Latin and
Roman setting and creating almost like
an encyclopedia wouldn't it be nice to
have this we know that it influenced
locked-on seus and Augustine and Bowie
theas and other people and then it
disappears from
the scene so we don't really get much of
a chance to see what was in it there's a
few fragments from it a few passages but
we don't have too much so those are my
top 10 works from antiquity that I wish
we had I think you know this is not a
list that a lot of people would agree
with there's there's probably many other
works and thinkers that that some of my
viewers would would rather have and you
can certainly put those in in the
comments but those are the ones that I
would most like to have and the
reasonings why that's the case
you